i felt i should just at least try to
calm the waters here
um there seems to be a lot of discussion
about uh nicole kidman it should be
deborah messing
lucille ball and desi arnaz's daughter
lucy arnez
just wants everyone to chill out here's
the deal
what you should understand we are not
doing a remake of i love lucy
uh no one has to impersonate lucy
ricardo
on sunday lucy hit up facebook in an
attempt to calm down some fans who are
worked up about casting for the upcoming
film
being the ricardo's which was written
and will be directed
by aaron sorkin
[Applause]
last week deadline reported that nicole
kidman and javier bardem
were being eyed to play lucy and desi
and
well some fans weren't feeling that
taking to social media to suggest that
debra messing
take on the role instead yes yes
yes i agree deborah previously channeled
the iconic actress during an episode of
will and grace that aired in
april 2020. yes with vitamin a vegement
you can spoon your way to health
all you do is take a tablespoon after
every meal it's so tasty too
[Music]
at the time debra also shared this
behind the scenes moment from that
episode
on instagram hugging lucy writing that
she would quote
never forget this moment
we hugged i was completely overwhelmed
with emotion thank you lucy for making
my dream come true
it felt very much like like a sort of
nod to lucy and desi
oh and if all that wasn't enough when
fans started tweeting that they thought
deborah should land the part
she retweeted those messages adding
quote thank you sweets
and even confirmed she's available for
the gig
it's a done deal but the contracts
aren't actually signed
yeah so on sunday after that went down
lucy explained that while contracts have
not been signed yet
she's happy with the casting and she
wants fans to understand
that the upcoming amazon studios film is
not a remake of i love lucy
no one has to impersonate lucy ricardo
nor do the vitamin regimen routine
or the chocolate factory routine or any
of the silly things
it's the story of lucille ball my actual
mother
not lucy ricardo and her husband desi
arnez
my dad not ricky ricardo
lucy doubled down on all that driving
home that quote
very little of the show is actually i
love lucy type stuff
and fans won't be disappointed aaron has
done a wonderful job
of bringing these characters to life and
it's just a little
soup song it's a little slice of life
in in their journey it's not the whole
story it's not a biopic
from cradle to grave it is a two-hour
feature film
about these two people and some of the
remarkable things that they lived
through
so i hope i can set the record straight
here and just say stop arguing about
who should play it she doesn't look like
her her nose isn't the same she isn't as
funny
and just in case anyone was thinking
about continuing the casting debate
she made sure to shut that down just
trust us it's gonna be a nice film
and p.s the voting is over
i love all of you